we turn now to Colorado where your
President Joe Biden made a rare
appearance as uh usual as per usual
didn't go well in fact the trip started
with a very concerning moment during a
photo op with workers at a Wind Tower
Factory Biden randomly started talking
about the nuclear codes okay watch this
now look my my Marine carries that has a
code to blow up the world that doesn't
this is not nuclear weapons is it all
right
okay okay Joe Biden was not coherent
pretty much all day Dazed and Confused
even when reading the giant sized font
on his teleprompter take a look for
yourself but but I am friends with your
leader Mr Moon you know home you know
we're we're good guys here in Colorado
the wind turbine manufacturing
vist is is investing $40 million to
expand his Factory and hire an
additional $1,000 employees solar
manufacturer B Meer Berger is building a
new solar cell Factory just down the
road in Colorado Springs instead of
cutting them like Congressman Trump and
bber want to do we could use it to help
millionaires millions of families afford
instead of millionaires millions of
families
afford little help with senior
care can someone interpret that for me
Congressman Trump uh what was Biden
actually trying to say how on Earth is
HE capable of being president this is
the toughest job in the world and he
wants to serve another 5 years uh has he
lost his mind uh I think it's becoming
quite transparent yes Biden is a
cognitive wreck I know it you know it
Democrats know it and but barring some
major trip and fall or emergency health
condition it looks like Joe is on a path
to be the nominee for the Democratic
party so given Biden's condition well
that means his vice president president
plays an important role unfortunately
his vice president happens to be kamla
Harris who polls lower than him and
today she couldn't come up with a simple
answer to a pretty simple question about
Tik Tok take a look you don't have a
specific view on on Tik Tok itself I'm
Notting on that are you want Tik toct
yourself I am not do you are you not
like a people in my family are I'll tell
you that and you tell them to get
off you know you can tell young people
in your family all kinds of things to
do well we got the Giggles but we didn't
talk about Vin diagrams as she calls
them whatever they are anyway unlike
kamla Harris my next guest has taken
tough action against Tik Tok it is now
backing a bill preventing China and
foreign adversaries from buying up us
Farmland they've also been buying Ranch
Land and land near military installation
joining us now South Dakota governor
Christy gnome uh Governor let's talk
about why the danger with Tik
Tock oh my goodness I can't believe she
actually said that she wasn't going to
comment on that they literally l l
banned it from federal devices after we
took action in South Dakota we banned
Tik Tock we're the first state to do it
30 states have done it since then but
the federal government took action and
banned it too so how can she
legitimately sit there and go yeah I'm
not going to comment they know and they
acknowledged that it is a national
security threat grow up and have an
opinion if you're going to be the vice
president of the United States just give
us an honest answer for once that's
what's so shocking to me is the way
Biden and Cala still think they have to
dance around everything the one thing
this country is desperate for is the
truth just tell the truth we have an
opinion we banned it we don't think it's
good all right move on yeah well you
know one of the things is it a spy
mechanism Governor is it a spy mechanism
okay so the answer is yes and the
experts tell us okay can you explain
something to me and you know as I look
at the people that are coming into this
country unvetted at our Southern border
we're finding people from Iran and Syria
uh tens of thousands from Russia and
China uh were allowing the Communist
Chinese to buy up Farmland Ranch Land
and then land near military
installations if I wanted to buy land in
China would I be allowed to do that I
tented out
it no you would not be allowed to do
that let me be clear Sean it's I've I've
kind of lost my filter tonight if you
are using Tik Tock you are helping China
destroy America you are facilitating it
so get off of Tik Tock take a little bit
of pause on what you think is fun and
let's start doing the hard work of
saving freedom and it's the same thing
with purchasing Farmland uh we have
National Security interests in this
country that our kids and grandkids are
going to depend on and we have to ensure
that people that want to destroy us do
not own land right next door to those
military installations that control the
weapons that will keep us safe so uh
this this investment that China has made
in purchasing up our assets our land is
extremely dangerous it's just the next
step in in lining up the tools that they
need to control us and they've been very
clear about this for Generations uh
they've been very clear that they have a
long-term agenda to become the dominant
superpower in the world and for them to
do that the United States of America
cannot exist let me ask you we just uh
heard about the passing of Henry
Kissinger a Monumental figure on the
world stage for such a long period of
time I had numerous opportunities to
interview him meet with him talk with
him a brilliant man uh in so many ways
uh you talking about China uh he played
a huge role in the Nixon Administration
in in their efforts to open up
discussions with China at that time um
making a lot of history doing so your
your reaction to his
death it's a sad day for us because he
was a leader that led l through
challenging times and I hope that
everyone's reaction to his passing is to
go learn a little bit more about him
that you didn't know before uh around
your dinner table or when you're driving
in the car with your kids tell them a
few kissing your Co quotes that that
were used at strategic times give them a
little bit of History because if we
forget uh what happened in the past
we're doomed to repeat it and many times
throughout history the United States of
America went through dark times and
leaders like Kissinger stood up and they
took action and they provided leadership
when we needed it the most yeah uh
Governor gnome great to see you we
really appreciate it um by the way uh we
will talk more about it uh coming up in
the course of the program tonight we'll
have more information about it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else